I always had a master plan I was trying  to push myself to me playing a game you  noticed the people that I really want to  win chopped to my man Dave East that's a  real new one  I see similarities with me in a day it's  just a drive she has that thing every  day you don't get drunk on power you use  it to help others what is more valuable  than diamonds though you're my idols  I'm to Paris also known as - yeah I'll  deal with them the moment I started to  learn how treacherous my neighborhood  was if somebody don't speak good Liberty  no longer I've never done this before  I miss Sumer  we are justifying what's going on  instead of saying this has to be stopped  only hope I think cuz the forces such as  yourself he go again  [Music]  you  you